ellie mistahl who you may have seen him
on msnbc or cnn actually you probably
haven't because you don't watch those
channels but
but he's he writes for the nation he's a
left-wing political analyst of some
prominence ellie mustall goes on he's
speaking to the cackling hens on the
view they're saying clock clock clock
and then somehow the constitution comes
up and eliminal he comes out and says
the quiet part out loud he says he hates
the constitution
some will say okay so are you arguing
for throwing out the constitution should
the constitution be thrown out what do
we do is it a living document is it a or
is it a sacred document it's certainly
not sacred all right let's start there
the constitution is kind of trash now
let's just again let's just talk as
adults first what did you say it's what
it's kind of trash trash it was it was
written by slavers and colonists and
white people who were willing to make
deals with slavers and colonists they
didn't ask anybody look like me what
they thought about the constitution
let's talk like adults for a second yes
nothing says talking like an adult like
ellie mistahl
on the view yes that how how mature how
responsible and sophisticated
certainly not sacred our constitution
and it's kind of trash he's talking like
a a freshman in high school let's talk
like adults it's kind of trash
and then joy behar you look over joy
behar
pretty left wing pretty disrespectful of
america in many ways she hears this and
even she goes what did you say
it's you said it's trash
when you are too far left
for joy behar you have gone really far
but
i suspect elimistal is actually
representing the accurate perception of
the constitution on the left
i don't think he's just some crazy
fringe element i mean the left has been
telling us this for years they protest
the american flag on football fields and
elsewhere they
denigrate the founding fathers and
framers of the constitution as he does
as slavers they're slavers
so that's why they
everything they ever touched was
terrible and turned to ash like this
wonderful country that has allowed me to
prosper even me ellie mustal a dum-dum
uh they're trash it's total trash of
course you know you notice the people
who denigrate our forebears they never
look at the things we're doing right now
that our posterity might say about us
they they never imagine that some some
day hundreds of years from now
people will look back at ellie mistahl
and the women of the view and say these
people were trash they defended killing
almost a million babies a year and they
pretended it was some sort of sacred
right
these people are trash
you know you want to compare the
founders and the framers to anyone at
least they weren't killing a million
babies a year okay
actually what whatever the and also by
the way
most of the founders and framers
virtually all of them had deep moral
misgivings about slavery and a lot of
them wanted to get rid of it even at the
time of the constitution it was just
politically impossible putting that
aside
if you're if you're comparing heaps of
trash you know everyone's trash
all fall short of the glory of god all
sin everyone's trash would seem to me
that
the view and ellie mestall certainly
beats the
founders and framers in magnitude and
stench of the trash
but the battle right now
you'll notice is over
not the constitution when ellie mistel
says the constitution is terrible and
trash
he doesn't actually make an argument
about the constitution he makes an
argument about the people who wrote the
constitution and he says these were bad
people therefore throw out the
constitution so the and and this is
this is defined you know it's it's
actually a pretty telling clip even
though the things that he's saying are
extremely stupid it's telling because
that's what our battle over who we are
as a country has been about it's not
really about the principles of the
constitution
on the rare occasion that someone brings
up a principle of the constitution they
usually do so to misrepresent it they'll
say you know in the constitution slaves
were only counted as three-fifths of
people can you believe that those
racists those well do you know what the
three-fifths compromise was do you know
what the point of that was yeah
yeah they said the founders said that
the slaves were three-fifths and well
actually there were two groups one group
wanted the slaves to be counted as
fullest people and the other group
didn't want the slaves to be counted as
people as at all
and
the the group that wanted the slaves to
be counted fully as people were the
slavers
usually people who invoke the
three-fifths compromise as some terrible
aspect of american history don't realize
that it was the slave holders who wanted
the slaves to be counted as fully as
people because they wanted more
representation in the congress
in no small part to better entrench
slavery it was the
northerners and the people who opposed
slavery who didn't want the slaves to be
counted at all because they wanted to
reduce the influence of the southern
slave holding states in
the government
so on the rare occasion that someone
brings up a provision of the
constitution it's usually just a
misrepresented usually the battle is
over the founders and the framers
jefferson had slaves
and washington had slaves and so the
founders were bad
and then on the right you have people
say no the founders were really good and
they were smart and they gave us a good
country and therefore
because the founders were good and the
framers were good we should support the
constitution and on the left they say no
because the founders of the frameworks
were bad we should oppose the
constitution there is a third way here
though
and i think this would be the better way
for
conservatives to defend our country the
left has already done a great job in the
cultural battle
of tearing down the statues of
denigrating washington and jefferson and
lincoln actually the refounding of the
country
what if we focus on the principles
themselves and what if we focus on our
constitutional system and and the law in
general not just as
some random preference of some old guys
in the late 18th century
a preference that could be good or bad
depending on your view of these guys
what if we view the law as something
that is objective
that is objectively true what if we
start making points like hey
the commandment thou shalt not commit
murder is just true it's true whether
dudes in philadelphia think it's true or
not it's it's a part of the natural law
it's a part of the transcendent moral
order that is just always true and from
that natural law we get other laws more
particular laws that you might call it
the law of nations adrian vermeel the
conservative harvard law professor has a
good book out about this and from the
law after the law of nations at the
smaller level you have the civil law
and then we have the particular laws
that we all make in our own towns and
states and in our own
countries but what if
the process of of law
we're not so much making law just
pulling it out of thin air but what if
it were actually discovering law that
some things are true
whether we whether we want them to be
whether we don't want them to be what if
we ground our defense of america and
that some things are just true and some
things are just good
and it's not about the personal virtues
or foibles of any founders or framers
it's about what's good and what's true
what if we had the guts to actually say
that and defend it right now go to
hunterdouglas.com
knowles i did not realize back when i
was an ignorant bachelor how important
window treatments are for your home i
don't think i'm exaggerating when i say
window treatments might be the single
most important thing you can do for your
home because window treatments determine
how the light comes into your home and
the light hitting your home is what
makes it so beautiful hunter douglas can
help you they've got innovative window
shade designs gorgeous fabrics control
systems so advanced they can be
scheduled to automatically adjust to
their optimal position throughout the
day maybe it's the way the shades
diffuse harsh sunlight to cast a
beautiful glow across the room or being
able to enjoy the view outside the
window while protecting your privacy
inside maybe it's the superior
insulation the shades provide keeping
you warmer in winter
cooler in summer and lowering utility
bills something really important right
now
whatever it is head on over to
hunterdouglas.com
knowles today get your free style get
smarter design guide with fresh takes
creative ideas and smart solutions for
dressing your windows hunterdouglas.com
knowles head on over there for your free
design guide i'm glad you like that clip
now i need you to subscribe
ring that bell
hopefully get the notifications if
you're not getting notifications head on
over to apple podcast spotify stitch or
google play wherever you get your audio
podcasts subscribe leave a five star
review we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]